elle est sympathique je veux laisser pas
servi de pécho des grands mères non mais
c'est la première fois que je n'ai
interview je trouve qu'elle est vraiment
chantage avec le jeune grand mère elle a
oublié sa carte de bons clients tout le
monde en parle je pense que c'est là sa
carte d'accord et moi je dois t celle là
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi secours aux eaux
bongo
ap
pourquoi
la prochaine fois que ça recommence je
te casse pas la gueule je te détruire ça
donne et arras
tu as donné ta mère à l'école qu'à
shoshana faut pas la faire chier
je suis en forme en ce moment mais
kouachi richard grosse [ __ ]
serge faut faire quelque chose c'est
possible on peut plus le tenir cet homme
[Musique]
encore je te remercie j'ai failli me
faire massacrer par cette grossesse
n'est pas intervenue bon allez on place
je te faire mal parce que c'est terminé
pourquoi t'es pas intervenue exactement
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
1 pouces bleus